my entire life I've wanted to be an
engineer for one I let Andy you know you
realize this could be risky like you
could lose all your money but I told you
this I don't see any risk Sun
Microsystems the company that changed
the world and then disappeared Into Thin
Air
we all know about revolutionary Tech
inventions like the iPhone the computer
the internet and the cloud
but these were the guys who made each
and every one of these inventions what
they are today for example they're the
ones who created the Java programming
language while Java has declined in
popularity in recent times it's still
one of the most influential coding
languages in the world it's used in
everything from laptops and computers to
gaming consoles smartphones and data
centers not to mention thousands of
languages and platforms have been
heavily inspired by Java likely the best
example is Android in fact Google ended
up fighting a several year-long Court
battle after copying Java code into
Android
but Java was just one of Sun's many
Innovations
sun is also the ones behind spark or
scalable process architecture again this
is probably something that most of you
have never heard of but spark
revolutionized chip design with spark
Sun basically figured out how to Triple
the number of instruction sets that a
given chip could handle and it wasn't
long until this technology made its way
into open source projects supercomputers
and basically became the new gold
standard for chip design
speaking of gold standards Sana also set
the gold standard when it came to
Enterprise software
Sans Solaris is a Unix based operating
system that was created way back in 1993
but to this day Solaris is the go-to OS
for powering many back-end
infrastructures they're basically the
windows of the back end but all of that
is just a handful of Sun's contributions
they also play critical roles in the
development of virtual computers
virtualization cloud computing database
management supercomputers and so much
more but despite their Monumental role
in Tech not many people are familiar
with sun today this is primarily because
Oracle bots on in 2009 and they
basically killed the brand
but while this on a brand May no longer
be a thing there's no question that
their inventions and Innovations will
live on for decades if not centuries
so here's the story of the company that
changed the world and then disappeared
Sun Microsystems
[Music]
yeah look back The Story of Us on
Microsystems can be traced back to their
early 1980s to a Stanford PhD student
named Andy bechtelsheim Andy was nothing
less than a tech genius at Stanford his
main project was creating a powerful
Network that could link the various
Departments of the University he called
this network Eason workstation with its
understanding for Stanford University
Network this network was extremely
complex for the time and required
several managers engineers and support
staff but it also linked together
computers like never before
fun fact two of these managers would
steal this deck and create Cisco which
would go on to become the world's
largest company but that's a whole other
story
going back to Andy while he was a genius
we can't give him all their credit as he
did have a bunch of help from our good
old friends Xerox
Xerox was honestly just idiots they had
no conception of what intellectual
property was or why they should protect
IP one of the most notable examples of
this was their no fee consultant program
essentially instead of paying
Consultants with cash Xerox opted to
give Consultants free access to their
research
almost instantly the sun workstation
attracted a bunch of scientists and
Engineers who were willing to pay big
bucks to use the workstation
so Andy would a nonchalantly priced
licenses to his workstation at 10 000
each
that's equivalent to thirty three
thousand dollars today
little to say Andy was racking in the
dough in 1981 and it wasn't long until
he threw the attention of a few MBA
graduates vinod khosla and Scott McNeely
basically they told Andy what you have
here is great but join us and we can
make this revolutionary that's exactly
what they did on February 24 1982 the
trio would establish Sun Microsystems
based on the sun Workstation
Bill Joy was one of the first employees
to join the company and he has since
been credited as a co-founder as well
and with that sun was in business they
began selling their son one and son to
workstations which were largely inspired
by Andy's original workstation and let's
just say these sold like hot cakes
basically every University in the world
wanted one of these workstations leading
to 8 million dollars in sales in just
the first year alone also we should note
that unlike many startups today that
burned money for decades Sun achieved
profitability within its first quarter
this gave them quite a bit of Leverage
when it came to recruiting the best
talent one of their first hires was Eric
Schmidt and a Carol Bart if you're not
familiar with these two Eric would go on
to be the CEO of Google and the Carol
would go on to be the CEO of Yahoo
so son had a pretty strong team to say
the least but they were just getting
started virtually all of their revenue
was coming in from universities and
research institutions and while that was
already super lucrative they knew that
the real money was with companies and
that was their real Target
hearing about all of these super
successful people I know a lot of y'all
wonder why they never stopped to just
enjoy life for example why did Elon
gamble his Paypal money on Tesla and
SpaceX and why is he still working 120
hours every single week well I don't
know the answer to that but what I do
know is that one of some Founders
Renault koslav would do exactly what
y'all have been dreaming about just two
years after founding Sun at age 29 I
know it would have become a
multi-millionaire and he straight up
just retired after that he would just
spend his time investing in startups
which has made him a multi-billionaire
so looks like vinod was able to get off
the hedonic treadmill early on but the
rest of sun was just getting started Sun
would turn their focus on to design
companies that relied on CAD models
specifically computer vision computer
vision already had a contract with the
sun's biggest competitor Apollo computer
but Sun wasn't willing to accept this as
a lost opportunity they would
aggressively pitch sun and offers over
and over and over again until computer
vision finally agreed to give them a
shot for computer vision sun was just
one of their dozens of back-end Partners
but for sonnet this partnership was game
changing as it established them as a
reputable player other companies started
thinking if Sun is good enough for
computer vision it must be good enough
for us too and this was exactly the push
Sun needed to break into the Enterprise
Market there was only one more Major
Market left governments in 1984 Sun
would open a new subsidiary called Sun
Federal and it accomplished exactly what
you would think it sold workstations to
government and the given that Sana
already had quite a bit of notoriety
among schools and companies breaking
into the government Market that wasn't
too challenging in fact by 1991 sun was
delivering over half of all workstations
ordered by local state and federal
governments
all of this allowed sun to become the
fastest growing American company between
1985 and 1989 averaging growth of 145
per year
this meant that sun was able to achieve
1 billion dollars worth of Revenue
within just six years of being founded
clearly zon had become a serious company
that had a stronghold in a multitude of
markets but it's what Sun would do next
with all of this influence and power
that really made them legendary
as companies mature they usually get a
greedier and greedier they become
enthralled and trying to maximize market
share maximize profits and maximize the
stock price of course son also wanted to
accomplish this but giving back to the
tech world was arguably of equal
importance for them one of their first
revolutions was the network file system
or NFS in 1984. before NFS file sharing
systems were usually limited to specific
processors and specific operating
systems companies did this to maximize
the sales of their own Hardware similar
to what Apple does today but sonnet
through this ideology completely out the
window with NFS
Affairs allowed for data sharing
regardless of processor type Os or
communication system
unsurprisingly this became the industry
standard within no time leading us to
spark
until the introduction of spark
virtually all chips were built on Sisk
or complex instruction set Computing
architecture spark however was based on
risk or reduced instructions at
Computing architecture risk was not only
more powerful and cheaper but more
importantly it was magnitudes more
scalable so switching to sport-based
workstations was a no-brainer for
customers but Sun didn't just stop right
there naturally when you have control of
such technology you'd want to patent the
hell out of it and make sure that no one
else gets access to it but Sun would do
the exact opposite
in fact Sun would begin licensing their
risk design to other chip makers for
cheap prices before they even launched
their own risk-based Workstation
their reasoning was that if they really
wanted to push forward the tech industry
and make risk the new standard they
needed all the help they could get and
it doesn't stop right there either Sun
would actually go on to hand over their
rights to spark to a non-profit
organization that was jointly owned by a
bunch of computer companies to be honest
I can't think of another Tech Giant as a
voluntarily given away such technology
since then let me know if you can think
of one in the comments below anyway all
of this brings us to Sun's most notable
contribution Java Java was the
brainchild of sun engineer James Gosling
with the substantial support from Sun
CEO is Scott McNeely
Scott believed that personal computers
were just a blip in history and that the
real invention was network computing
back in the 1990s he predicted that
everything from refrigerators and
telephones to credit cards and door
locks would all be connected by a
network he wanted all the backend
infrastructure that was powering these
Technologies to run on Java and to
accomplish that in Classics on style he
would open source Java let's just say
Scott was spot on with his vision and he
more than accomplished his goal with
Java it looks like giving away all this
Tech didn't take away from Sun
throughout the 1990s asan would achieve
a peak market cap of 200 billion dollars
but unfortunately the sun would
eventually set
the bottom line is that all of a Sun's
generous sharing eventually came back to
bite them you see even though some open
sourced a bunch of their greatest text
throughout the 1990s it didn't really
hurt them then because companies would
opt to buy the official Sun version of
their product this was things that loads
of VC funding and entrepreneurs with
sky-high visions but after the.com
bubble popped this reality quickly
crumbled away all of a sudden the
cheaper workstations from Dell and IBM
based on the same ticket seemed a lot
more attractive so customers ditched sun
and droves and us on tried to compete
against these lower cost Alternatives
their profit margins would get slashed
driving them into unprofitability pretty
soon Sun fell from being the market
leader with the 200 billion evaluation
to being the drowning giant that needed
a bailout IBM would offer 7 billion
dollars persona but it was Oracle that
ended up snatching the company for 7.4
billion once Oracle took over though the
soul of sun was basic destroyed
completely instead of keeping up Sun's
tradition of contributing to and
advancing the tech World Oracle would
focus on milking Sun for maximum profit
but can you really blame them Sun had
already tried to do the right thing and
make technology as accessible as
possible but while this strategy worked
out fine during good times as soon as
bad times hit they were the first to get
slaughtered and that's the story of the
company that changed the world and
disappeared were you guys familiar with
sun Microsystems comment that down below
also drop a like if you respect son for
trying to do something that no other
tech company has dared to attempt and of
course consider checking out our Discord
Community suggest for the video ideas
and to consider subscribing to see more
questions and logically answered but
until then I'm Hari and Aussie guys on
the next one
[Music]
foreign